I've got some bad news for Hillary
Clinton the Justice Department has just
reportedly reopened the investigation
into the former Secretary of State's use
of a private email server something
president Trump has been asking for
quite a while a source tells The Daily
Beast Attorney General Jeff Sessions
describes the probe as a way of
gathering new information about the
handling of classified documents by
Clinton and her aides and there's
clearly reason for more investigating
Judicial Watch just found out that at
least 18 classified emails were found on
Anthony Weiner's laptop he's of course
the husband of Hillary's top aide Huma
Abedin so Gregg do we just need to let
this thing go or do you think there's
real reason to dig back into it I just
feel bad for every investigator that has
to handle Anthony Weiner's laptop the
guys come in hazmat suits anybody in
lower office would be getting three hots
and a cot which is a prison not a dr.
Seuss book the only thing is I guess at
least somebody's being consistent about
this in the sense that it's like it's
like Trump is like a dog that already
caught the car and actually kept running
I mean it's like it's a he still wants
to do this wasn't gonna do it when he
was a look and said he was gonna let
bygones be bygones but now I guess after
he's been attacked
yeah he's gonna turn up the heat on the
left well it'll be interesting to see if
the DOJ is really doing anything this is
a story to do job right leaked to The
Daily Beast you know these stories that
say you had one Republican leaning
strategist saying well this makes sense
because you would have finally some
nonpartisan people and objective people
look at her email situation then you
have the other thing which is the White
House continues to agitate about
so Jeff sessions like dribble something
out every once in a while just to keep
the president satisfied and to keep the
stories going that Hillary Clinton is
really the culprit on emails do you
think Jeff sessions has been browbeaten
by the president or the library
yeah well no I've been lucky
will you go where justice leads you
right and he should be doing an
investigation if there's new evidence
that's come to light you have an
obligation to go forward and actually
examine it or you give a full fair and
impartial evaluation of what's the crime
is there one scintilla Russians got any
intelligence from Hillary Clinton's
private email server have we beaten this
thing to death this is like Benghazi you
already ruined the career of trey Gowdy
ruin the career of Jason jason Chaffetz
got hired here that's my point about the
consistency if you don't need this story
anymore you won the election you would
let it go but by not letting it go it
shows that you're actually moral you
lied on something you're not ruining
someone's career in fact chief it's sad
and Jesse C talked about The Daily Beast
getting this leak okay so what's the big
headline in The Daily Beast story that
there was some guy some guy that
serviced her private computer net lied
to the FBI and misled the FBI they did
they chose not to prosecute him they
gave him an immunity instead so you guys
got immunity so where does it go from
there
it goes no place this is a waste of time
and it distracts the Department of
Justice makes them look like lackeys
make session look like a like a like
Kate McKinnon on Saturday Night Live for
goodness sake jumping out of the closet
and sitting on Trump's lap I mean it is
really I'm so sick of it Hillary email
is is it's like Benghazi
it's it's like that guys in the sense
there's nothing there there there was
nothing fun you want to go into the
Democrats on something that makes sense
we're all in on Benghazi on this Sh I
think yeah I think when they blame
Benghazi on a video that was a pretty
big lie and put the guy in guy who did
the video the first million times I was
would think you can't 60 millionth time
I don't ever let anybody forget a lie
that they haven't yet admitted well i'ma
forget it how can they possibly really
lived off that lie she's living I'll be
back there they're such here you have
you have the American economy humming
along get people all right great full
employment yep you can walk into my
sense of optimism damn about what if you
wanted to look backwards into this he's
using it as leverage because they're
turning the screws to him on some unfair
stuff with ashes that that's all right
and you said lock her up in the green
room and I'm not gonna